-Welcome back, everybody.
We have a little --
We have a special guest
with us right now.
-Yes.
This is Diamond Baby.
-Hi, Diamond Baby.
Nice to see you.
I thought that would be
the biggest surprise,
but we also have
another surprise.
Your mom is here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Kathy Hilton.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes!
You are unbelievable.
-Mwah!
-You are the funniest person
on television right now.
-Hi, Mom.
-Welcome to the show.
-Hi, honey. How are you?
-You look beautiful.
-Mwah!
-Now, I thought it'd be fun
to have both
of you guys together
and play a game with you.
Because you always give out
great advice.
And I thought, right now,
it would be fun.
We could help some people out
with their big-time
life decisions.
It's time for "Life Coach
with Paris and Kathy Hilton."
-♪ Life Coach
with Paris and Kathy ♪
-So, we had viewers
send in some questions.
We've got some pretty good ones.
How about this one?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I know those people.
I would just say,
show the picture once.
'Cause nobody really cares,
truthfully.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so mean.
-One picture.
That's enough.
-They don't really --
Yeah, you're right.
That's true.
-They don't care.
-But when you first
become a parent, though,
all you do is show pictures
to everybody.
I'm showing my cab driver.
I'm like,
"Dude, look at my baby.
And he's like, "Yeah."
-That was Rick, my husband.
-Okay. He showed it
to everybody, yeah.
-I think that's so rude because
you could really hurt someone,
and people are really struggling
right now.
And it's just not nice.
If you don't have something
nice to say,
don't say anything at all.
-I love that.
[ Applause ]
Can't top that.
I agree with you.
Don't do that.
-No, that's mean.
I love that.
All right. How about this?
-I wasted three years
on my cellphone and my iPad.
No, I'm not kidding.
-Three years of your life gone.
-Three years gone.
Wasting, just sitting there.
And it would get dark.
-Wow.
And what do you do now?
-Now I'm working.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so, you don't need --
How about you?
-I would probably need
to ask that advice, as well,
because I'm addicted
to my phone.
[ Laughter ]
-That question came from you.
All right, perfect.
-It was me.
-I heard, like,
if you want to -- when you go
to bed, you put the phone --
you charge it in another room.
No?
-I need the alarm.
I need a sleep fan
or something.
I don't know. I can't sleep
without, like, a noise.
-You too, right?
-We both have the fans.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my --
All right.
How about this?
-Wear sunglasses.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow! A pro!
-I love it.
-Wow, a pro right there.
Don't stop rolling.
Just wear sunglasses.
Perfect.
Probably goes with your ape.
-I can relate to that,
but it's the opposite.
I'm the night owl,
and then, my husband is, like,
the early riser
and goes to bed early.
So, I try to get him
to stay up later.
So, I don't know.
Just try to change
your sleeping schedule
or tell the other person
to wake up earlier or something.
-The other person.
-Wow.
Kathy, any advice on that?
-I would -- I think I'm --
Rick goes to bed.
I stay up later on the iPad.
So, I think he's got to
get an iPad
so we can do it together.
[ Laughter ]
-You're both on the iPad?
Yeah.
All right, this one says...
-I know who wrote this question.
-You do?
-I do.
Don't you know?
-No.
-I think I do.
I think it's the octopus,
Carter.
-What?
-We call Carter the Groomzilla
and the Octopus.
-'Cause he's got his mitts
into everything.
-So, you think Carter
wrote this.
-Read it again.
-"I want to quit my job
and travel, but I'm afraid of
finding work when I'm back.
Should I just do it anyway?"
-What?
It has nothing to do with him.
-Well, because --
[ Laughter ]
-He did travel with you on
a long holiday, your honeymoon.
-Yeah, but he's working
non-stop.
-I know.
-With this new world,
you can work from anywhere
with Zoom.
-I get it.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, wow.
The Octopus.
Oh, my God.
-No, he does.
He's got his mitts
into everything.
And Paris is right.
She goes,
"Mommy, he means well."
But he was offending me.
He was calling the cake place.
He was calling the band.
He was calling --
-Talking about the wedding?
-The party planner.
-Yes, he's very organized.
-The band, the hotels.
Everything.
-But he's the groom.
-I know.
I said, "This is not normal."
[ Laughter ]
He even picked out
the invitation
and the save-the-date cards.
I was like, "Okay."
-He's just very responsible,
very organized, and we're not.
-What do you guys think?
Come on?
[ Laughter ]
-All, right, how about this?
Ready?
-To me, I really think that you
send out love and good wishes.
And I just put, like --
If they're unkind,
put, like, a little sad emoji.
[ Laughter ]
No, I mean that, really.
-Just let them know it's sad.
-The fact that
they're giving you attention,
they do care about you.
So, then I just write,
"Oh, I'm sorry
if I offended you,"
or I put an emoji like that.
And then, they're sweet,
and they feel bad.
[ Laughter ]
-Kill them with kindness.
I like that.
-Yes.
Grandma used to say that.
-All right, good.
Kill them with kindness.
I'll take that.
I love it.
That is all the time we have for
"Life Coach
with Paris and Kathy Hilton."